should the color of your skin matter if
you behave badly in class well Portland
Public Schools must now consider race or
gender identity when dishing out
discipline the student who act up
according to a new Collective bargain
agreement reached between the district
and its teachers union Educators must
develop quote unquote a support plan for
the disruptive students that will quote
take into consideration the impact of
issues related to the students trauma
race gender identity presentation sexual
orientation and restorative justice as
appropriate for the student when I did
not respond to my principal and teacher
after recess coming in on time they
didn't take into account any of these
things in second grade when I got
paddled did you ever take into account
any of this stuff when you were a judge
when you were meeting out these kind of
factors I could care less here here this
is the student the the teachers union is
supporting this and what they're doing
is they're turning schools into blue
cities where the teachers unions are
basically now the the mayors of the
schools and they're saying that if
you're suffering from trauma what is
trauma kids today think it you know if
they got Short Change five cents it's
trauma everything is traumatic to them
but what's going on is they said look
students of color uh are suspended more
than more often than whites and we don't
wanted to suspend them that much so
we're going to Define deviancy down
where uh we have an uncivilized barbaric
society that keeps devolving until we
reach the lowest of the low where
everybody's in agreement and we get the
same level of punishment it it makes no
sense to me all they're doing is they're
using color as an excuse to get away
with everything it's kind of like Lowden
County if you're a sexual predator in
the school in Lowden County but you
identify as a as a female they'll just
send you to another school so you can
you know uh commit a sexual crime
against another kid based on your sexual
identity it's an excuse Greg in The
Green Room you said that certain kids
should be beaten eat more than other
kids I didn't say certain I said all
kids I hate it when you misquote me but
U speaking of quoting VI ramaswami
tweeted the perfect two sentences to
describe the current state of racial
delusion he said the left says your race
and sexuality govern who you are and
what you can achieve if you question
them they call you racist think about
that and he calls it psychological uh
slavery but I was thinking think about
how small your world gets based on
identity right how it shrinks your
universe so it's just you and your
so-called lived experience I think this
is why we see so many miserable people
because identity politics is the enemy
of human connection it's a tribe of one
you know it's not being an individual
it's being a collection of all these
self-imposed markers it's why among the
woke you know the the self-description
gets more partical ised
non-binary differently abled uh
neurodiverse Woodland creature of color
they just shrink themselves down and
further and further into like a
microscop scopic lived experience that
you cannot share with them and that's
the point the joy of life if I may say
so Dana is seeking to get outside your
lived experience which is what we call a
connection right I don't want to be in a
tribe of Greg gutfeld's that would be
horrible I want a diverse world of
thought and not identity people who
reject identity politics are generally
most interesting people the people who
embrace it you will notice are the most
boring dull dull as dishwater B probably
Jessie watersa may have a problem
understanding this are people who were
not didn't show discipline in school I
know this is hard for you to comprehend
people who would actually get punished
in school but this is a you know this is
a crazy idea you would have to I think
it is a crazy idea it's also one that
parents reject so parents defending
education did a poll and only 177% of
parents think that schools are doing a
good job of discipline and 73% of
parents disagree with using race when it
comes to discipline so once again the
left Progressive left is pushing an
agenda item that the vast majority of
Americans do not agree with plus the
public Union the teachers union in
Portland has basically made these kids
stay home for a month how do you think
their discipline is going right the
teachers have been striking these kids
have not been in school the parents had
to figure out something else for them to
do and I think it shows why public
sector Union should be legally
prohibited from going off the job and
that would help helpfully protect the
children because guess what next they're
going to ask all of us to pay for their
free community college and to repay
their student loans as they continue to
go through this life of
Julia I remember you've talked a lot
about your time in school and some of
the skirmishes you had is how do you
feel about this issue young Jesse would
have thrived in
Portland I would have come out of the
closet just to
misbehave I would have said Dean I'm not
sorry I'm
gay and I would have started food fights
and said I was 0.1% subsaharan African
I'd smash every women's swimming record
it would be amazing and who cares cuz my
parents can't complain they raise hell
at a school board meeting the FBI
arrests them Ben's party at the waters
household that weekend they're already
doing this in the criminal justice
system today you look at these antifa
people they're all getting their charges
dropped blm's getting charges dropped
you're a a legal alien you commit a
crime in a sanctuary city they're not
going to deport you this is what this is
though a lot of these teachers are women
and they are liberal men and they don't
like to administer discipline because it
makes them feel bad and they don't want
to feel bad and so they avoid discipline
because they don't want to confront the
feelings of implementing discipline so
they just avoid discipline and notice
it's all about how they feel it's not
about what's good for the kids just
about making them feel
better I wish I focus more on math and
science hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now